The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So this next exercise
is which of the following
is allowed in Python.
So x plus y is equal to 2.
And again, these are all
things that you can just
type into Anaconda, which
is our IDE for the class,
and see whether it works or not.
So this-- the first one is
probably not right-- let's
increase it a little
bit-- is not right
because the left side
needs to be a variable.
This is not right because
it's an expression.
This is not right because 2
is not a proper variable name.
And xy-- that one's
actually going
to be OK because it's
not multiplication,
it's just the variable xy.
So 50% said xy is equal
to 2, and that's right.
So none of these.
So just to make sure
that you guys understand,
xy, this last one
here, is the right one
because xy is not x
times y, like in math.
It's just one variable name that
has two characters, x and y.